[Music]
you know there's a lot more than ten
bucks on the line at Dancing with the
Stars and Rashad Jennings is a
front-runner to win it all which is a
lot of pressure but he's keeping it fun
as et online Stanny director found out
we should noise I think you can dress
the most funky you know we have a
competition within ourselves every day
it's called the reckless and zest for
life competition Rashad's clearly
winning competition but the free-agent
running back says the fancy footwork you
see in the ballroom doesn't come as easy
i'm never ballroom dance before every
single Tuesday is like banging my head
on the wall I don't know what I'm doing
every once in a while I'll look at the
tape I'll look at the video like hey
that's nice I do you are a born dancer
that was incredible
six weeks in the single thirty
two-year-old is a judge favorite and
still can't believe he was actually
picked for the show it still tickles me
now like even when we're when we're
behind the scenes doing everything I'm
still looking around I take a pencil
there's what starts since we still on
the show it is like wonder how far we
could get what has been the reaction
from the lady since you joined Dancing
with the Stars
oh it's been welcoming I really like it
yeah I'll say that much it's been pretty
welcoming we're a shot it's been merry
yeah that man is beautiful oh my
goodness did you realize like how sexy
your partner was when you when you got
them uh well yeah I've got a lighter so
yeah it yeah
[Music]